JUSTIN BROUGHTON: In
Firebase Test Lab,
you use real and virtual
devices to test your app.
These devices run in
a Google data center.
They contain the latest APIs
and have customizable locale
settings, enabling you to
test your app as people
around the world would use it.
You can let Test
Lab test your app
for you, which is
called Robo testing,
or you can create Espresso
Instrumentation tests
in Android Studio and
have Test Lab run them.
I will look at both of these
in more detail shortly.
You can also run Robo tests
from the Google Play Console
pre-launch report each
time you upload an app
to the closed or
open test tracks.
The pre-launch report offers
the same Robo test features
as Firebase Test Lab.
The benefit of Test
Lab comes from being
able to run tests on a wider
range of devices with more
options, as well as to be able
to run your own instrumentation
tests.
OK, let's take a close
look at Robo tests.
When you run a Robo test,
an application crawler
analyzes the structure
of your app's UI
and then explores
it methodically,
simulating user activity.
Robo tests capture log
files, performance data,
screenshots of unique screens,
as well as annotated video
to show you the simulated
user actions it performed.
These logs and performance
data and screenshots and videos
can help you determine
the cause of crashes
and find issues
with your app's UI.
You can also use Robo
tests to validate bug fixes
and test for regressions.
This is because Robo testing
simulates the same user
activities in the same order
each time it tests your app.
There is also an option
to control Robo tests.
For example, you may want to
test a common user journey
or start the crawler
at a specific screen.
You do this using a Robo script.
You create these scripts
in Android Studio, simply
select Firebase
from the tools menu,
then click Record Robo Script,
and use it to guide Robo test.
Now record and upload your
scripts to Firebase Test Lab.
In addition to a regular crawl
from the beginning of your app,
you can test up to
three deep links.
Here, the crawler
follows the link
and then exercises your app
for an additional 30 seconds,
reporting on anything
it finds in the same way
as it does for the main test.
Robo test can also sign into
your app using either a Google
login or your own custom
login credentials.
Robo tests are a great way to
get started with app testing
with minimal effort
on your part.
However, for a truly
high quality app,
you will almost
certainly need to create
your own instrumentation
test which Firebase Test
Lab can then run for you.
You can create these test
scripts in Android Studio
either manually,
or you can record
them using Record Espresso
Test on the run menu.
You record your test script
by interacting with your app,
when done saving your
test script locally.
For more details on
recording test scripts,
check out the Android
Tool Time video,
Create UI Tests with
Espresso Test Recorder.
There is a link in
the video details.
To get the most out
of Espresso tests,
the key is to
modularize your tests,
creating test snippets
for the functions used
in the majority of your
tests, such as logging in
or filling out a search form.
You can then invoke these
snippets from your test scripts
whenever you need
these common functions.
Then as you update your app,
use Espresso Test Recorder
to quickly rerecord the snippets
where there have been changes.
You can then run these
test scripts locally
or load the suite of tests into
your continuous integration
server and get the
assurance that you haven't
broken your app at each update.
And of course, you can
upload the test scripts
to Firebase Test Lab.
You can then choose
to run the tests
on a selection of over 50
virtual and physical devices,
many of them available with
a range of Android versions.
Other options include
testing your app
in different languages or
screen orientations and more.
You can also run your
tests in Firebase Test
Lab from your continuous
integration server.
You can find details
on how to do this
from the link in the
video description.
Espresso Test
Recorder enables you
to quickly and
easily create tests
for all parts of your app.
You can then use the features
of a continuous integration
server, the pre-launch
report, and Firebase Test Lab
to automate your testing,
improving your app
quality, while freeing your
time to focus on development.
To find out about this
and other features
and get tips to grow your
app or game business,
check out the Playbook app,
available on Google Play.
Thanks for watching.